simplify 3 times the principal root of
500 x to the third power so we're going
to do here is try to break up the stuff
that we have under the radical sign into
some things that are perfect squares and
then we can separately take the square
root of those things and leave the
leftovers inside of the radical sign and
the other thing we have to remember is
principle square root this radical sign
here really means the positive square
root of a number so let's think about
this a little bit so let's see if we can
break down the 500 x to the third into
some perfect squares and some things
that maybe aren't perfect squares
because 500 is not a perfect square and
x to the third is not a perfect square
right from the get go so when we when
when in doubt we can just start to prime
factorize this and maybe we'll discover
some perfect squares so 500 is divisible
by 5 and it's 5 times 100
and you probably already recognize that
100 is a perfect square it is 10 times
10 but if you didn't know that you could
keep factoring it you could say look 100
is 2 times
50. 50 is 2 times 25 and 25 is 5 times
5. so you would see the perfect squares
here because you would see
you would see two twos
you would see two twos so you have a two
times a two and you have a five times a
five so you could really just say that a
hundred is ten times ten or you could
say it's two squared times 5 squared
either of those things would allow you
to break this down a little bit and then
x to the third that's clearly just the
same thing x to the third right over
here is clearly the same thing as x
squared times x which allows us to break
it down into a perfect square and
something that is not a perfect square
so let's just rewrite these numbers
under the principal root sign so this is
going to be equal to
3 times and i'll save some space here
three times
the 500 i can rewrite it as i can
rewrite it as a hundred times five and a
hundred i can rewrite as 10 squared
so this right here i can rewrite as 10
squared i don't have to do all of this
business down here but this will help
you recognize that it's a perfect square
it's 4 times 25 both of those are
perfect squares
so it's a 110 squared so i'm going to
write this as 10 squared
10 squared times
10 squared times 5. that's the 500
right over there and then i can rewrite
the x to the third as
as
x squared times x
x squared times x and then let me extend
my principal root sign right over here
and we know from basic exponent
properties because that's really what
we're doing here this taking the square
root of something is really the same
thing as taking it to a fractional
exponent so it's the same properties
that apply this is the same thing as 3
times the principal root of 10 squared
principle root of 10 squared times the
principal root let me do it this way
times the principal root of 5
times the principal root
times the principal root of x squared
times the principal root of x
and now we can simplify these things
so the principal root of 10 squared or
the principal root of 100 is going to be
positive 10. it
the negative 10 is also equal to 100 but
when you take the principal root you
only care about the positive square root
so this right over here is going to be
10.
5 is not a perfect square so we'll just
leave this expression as the square root
of 5.
square root of x squared so here you
might be tempted and this is i've seen
this done many many times you you're
tempted to just say hey that's just
going to be x the square root of x
squared is x
but what if what if x is negative so
what if
what if x is negative let's say that x
was negative 2
then x squared would be x squared would
be 4 and the principal root of 4 is
equal to positive 2. it's equal to the
positive square root so you can't just
say that this thing over here is going
to be equal to x because in this case it
was equal to the absolute value of x and
so that's what we do we say that this is
equal to
regardless of whether x is positive or
negative we want the positive square
root so you would say it's equal to the
absolute value of x that's what that
principle root does for us and so now if
we simplify it a little bit remember
with multiplication it doesn't really
and since we're just multiplying a bunch
of expressions here it doesn't matter
what order we do it we can switch the
order so we have all the stuff out of
the radicals multiplying times each
other first and then we have the
radicals so we have 3 times 10 times the
absolute value of x
3 times 10 3 times 10 is 30 so we have
times the absolute value of x
times the absolute value of x times the
square root of 5
times the square root of 5 times the
square root of x
times the square root of x and both you
have the principal root of the square
root of 5 and the square root of x you
can actually rewrite this right here as
the square root of 5x you're taking the
product of two things that are raised to
the same power that's the same thing as
taking their product and then raising
them to that fractional power or i guess
another way to think of it and then
taking the square root so this all
simplifies to 30
times the absolute value of x
times the absolute value of x times the
square root of 5 x